esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a que nada en las américas
café o el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
difusor público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a partir de las dos y cuarto por
internet
esta emisión también se encuentra
disponible en nuestro sitio en internet
heresi net punto sea les invitamos a
contactarnos con sus comentarios y
sugerencias nuestro correo electrónico
amlat arroba erice y net punto se a
nuestro correo regulares radio canadá
internacional apartado postal 6000
montreal canadá h 13 3 a 8 quienes
acompañan en los micrófonos dieron ahora
chapman pablo gómez barrio leonardo
gimeno y quienes habla ruso valencia en
la versión radio de este programa que
ustedes podrán encontrar en nuestro
sitio en internet podrán escuchar esta
semana temas el tema bosman del rumbo
del dúo de rock and roll héroes
canadienses club dulce y melissa
material
en escena en el cidam and white wars y
este es un matrimonio de verdad que
viven a milton en ontario también
escucharemos al grupo chicano las
cafeteras con el tema ya me voy porque
hoy hablaremos bastante sobre migración
este grupo musical estuvo de visita en
radio canadá internacional al igual que
el artista argentina gallegos de quien
escucharemos el tema carnavalito bien
amigos ese es el lo que ustedes figurará
en la versión de audio en nuestro sitio
de internet bienvenidos que como han
pasado estos siete días estamos ahora en
varias plataformas al mismo tiempo y
saludando también a muchos amigos
habría que tener entonces otra allá y
otra allá y tendríamos
como estamos ahora en el social en redes
sociales pero estamos saliendo en
youtube que pronto vamos a dar el nombre
del canal estamos ajustando un par de
cosas estamos saliendo o por lo menos es
el intento hoy es la programación sale
al mismo tiempo en el sitio de internet
pero hay un delay o sea que nosotros
empezamos y cuarto y 17 y 18 va a salir
en nuestros sitios de internet también
se desplaza el carrusel de la
de las noticias de los reportajes hoy
les voy a mostrar si me dejan 12
este es nuestro sitio de internet y aquí
van a tener un motorcito que dice
justamente un link que dice aquí ese uno
hace clic ahí y va a aparecer
todavía no pero ya va a aparecer la
emisión en directo desde nuestro sitio
también les va a ser una plataforma más
aparte del facebook y de youtube y
esperemos mientras no nos saturamos a
nuestros oyentes al contrario les da
mayores posibilidad de un segundo el
acceso que puedan tener o que tengan a
las redes sociales pues facilita yo creo
sí sí y el otro tema es que la
polifónica o como contábamos en la
semana pasada que facebook que está
cambiando su algoritmo y que va a dar
más preponderancia a la comunicación
entre amigos y no con los
los feeds de noticias entonces hay que
buscar alguna alternativa para que la
gente pueda encontrarlos por su
excelente bien empezamos entonces con
las noticias que las ha llamado la
atención esta semana no sé si quieres
empezar a leonora a mí me llamó
poderosamente la atención por lo
insólito ruffo
esta semana hubo una tormenta muy fuerte
de nieve de hielo cayó muchísimo hielo
había algunos de los hospitales no daban
abasto en quebec pero también en ontario
si no me equivoco y un montreal en si
ustedes saben que aquí las máquinas
tienen que pasar y limpiar la nieve y
para eso pues hay lugares específicos
donde se puede dejar el auto y donde no
se puede dejar el auto y vi la foto fue
una noticia publicada en radio canadá en
el servicio en lengua francesa un
artista de montreal
un escultor hizo un automóvil con la
nieve y el hielo pero tan bien hecho del
tamaño exacto con con los faros con las
ruedas parecía realmente un auto que la
nieve lo había cubierto pero toda la
forma del auto estaba perfecta una
escultura de hielo de hielo cubierta de
nieve no no se vende es decir impedía
que se viera el auto el tema era que era
una escultura y pasó un auto de policía
y le dejó una multa cuando sí porque
aparte el artista pues un artista el que
lo que hizo fue hasta puso un
limpiaparabrisas un pedazo de mitad
sí apoyado donde corresponde ya entonces
con el policía había en el momento
hubieron dos patrulleros porque deben
haber tomado a alguien para no irse
juntos vale y le dejaron una multa pero
en realidad la multa decía no no nos
hicieron y nos alegraron el día
esa fue la el mensaje escrito dentro de
la multa porque realmente es realmente
bueno eso fue insólito
me imagino que podremos presentar esa
foto o veremos si la encontramos para
presentar a nuestros oyentes pablo una
historia de pagos para vos
sí esa es una noticia insólita que
estuve leyendo en nuestro sitio de radio
canadá
bueno es una historia de pavos
silvestres en columbia británica al
parecer en un pueblito que se llama
edgewater hay alrededor de 100 pavos
silvestres que han escogido el sitio han
escogido al pueblo para instalarse ahí
entonces pues se son como un centenar de
pavos es toda una patrulla grande como
habrán gritado
y bueno ya estaba ocasionando algunos
problemas entre el pueblo entre la gente
del pueblo algunas personas se quejan
porque dicen que están que son pesados
no dicen que estos animales estos pavos
que estarían buenos para el horno si
vayan al césar hasta un metro de altitud
de altura un metro 20 centímetros son
grandotes son unos pasos guau son unos
señores oxidadas entonces lo que dicen
los vecinos es que cuando se suben a los
árboles están en los árboles y quiebran
las ramas de los árboles entonces están
destrozando una buena parte de los
árboles de la ciudad entonces pues
algunos temen
por la seguridad de los niños van para
la escuela porque no saben 7
y aparte de eso porque no saben si
pueden ser agresivos no entonces por eso
se te mstm por los niños entonces entre
otras cosas también se teme que sean un
obstáculo para la circulación en el
pueblo pero bueno yo digo nosotros que
si uno atropella a un pavo de esos o dos
más no se lo ponen bowl del carro y pal
horno no es ese sería la única
dificultad que yo vería en ese obstáculo
en el tráfico pero bueno me pareció
bastante insólito como noticia no que
estos pavos hayan invadido
el pueblo igual eso son cosas que solo
pueden ocurrir acá no sé yo me pregunto
si una situación parecida se pudiera
producir en américa latina con la nieve
no con el auto no pero con el pago
probable habría un festival del pavo la
hora
nuestros amigos tienen alguna idea
algunas sugerencias a lo mejor con
animales que hayan conocido alguna
historia de esta naturaleza que tiene
que haber claro
leonardo si en realidad no es algo
insólito pero me llama la atención
estamos a mediados casi comenzando el
mes de febrero y todavía no se habla del
mundial-2018 el fútbol porque hace frío
pero no no pero en todo el mundo se
habla mucho menos o mejor
no se no se sigue el cambio de la fifa
no sé si es que es en rusia
y creo que hay una estamos viendo de
nuevo quienes han vivido algunos bueno
las memorias de los años la guerra fría
esta nueva posición entre eeuu y ahora
rusia ahí está de por medio pero el
fútbol es el fútbol rufo claro claro
pero el fútbol no escapa hoy es que yo
estoy en contacto con gente en argentina
mira los medios de argentina y si hay un
movimiento pero a esta época en el 2014
habían publicidades en la gente hacía
programas hablando solamente del mundial
que se venía y ahora es como que si
rusia viene no será porque argentina no
logra ganar ese mundial que en argentina
están un poquito más allá pero que lo
vean otros países también he charlado
con gente de colombia por ejemplo que
sigue colomé tampoco hay un movimiento
tan grande como se ha visto en otros
años a lo mejor disipación o yo diría
con rufo en ese sentido pero no por la
guerra fría o porque puede haber
conflictos con eeuu o rusia sino porque
rusia queda tal
mentalmente geográficamente de américa
latina probablemente que a lo mejor eso
hace que se hable menos pero espérate
que empiece a ser un regreso es que no
está chile por eso
lo que destacó esta semana es mi interés
en los silencios y este caso un silencio
que encuentra en los medios y es que
estamos viendo una una euforia o una
preocupación sobre esta idea del libre
comercio está la renegociación del
tratado de comercio está el tratado de
comercial transpacífico que el primero
ya sentido afirmó en davos que si se
había firmado que eso es se fue esta
semana claro y si se ve y ahora trump
dice que él estaría interesado en firmar
porque acuérdense que fue el primero en
salir tiro abajo de esta idea de
firmarlo en su momento pues ahora está
diciendo que él estaría dispuesto a
firmar otro acuerdo transpacífico pero
con ciertas modificaciones
también dijo no para cambiar el tema
pero me extraña que estaría pensando en
la posibilidad de firmar el tratado de
parís del medioambiente con algunas
modificaciones
creo que este presidente de eeuu está
tal vez reflexionando un poco los
definición pero no lo reflexiona es
mucho decir es mucho decir traigo esto a
colación porque hay este un poquito del
mundo está embarcado en este baile pero
si tomamos dos elementos como son las
dos necesidades básicas como el alimento
y la ropa y si tenemos este empuje de
comprar y vender y comercializar
en los canadienses compran anualmente
770 prendas de vestir al año
esto se traduce en 12 millones de
toneladas anuales de ropa que se tira a
la basura algunos minoristas han lanzado
campañas de sostenibilidad y ha montado
contenedores pero esto no es una
solución ante la interminable cantidad
de ropa desechable que se fabrique se
comercia bajo el principio de libre
comercio el otro elemento en canadá 31
mil millones de dólares en alimentos
terminan en la basura cada año y en el
mundo según la fao se echan a la basura
mil trescientos mil mil trescientos
millones de toneladas de alimentos y
todo esto justamente detrás de esta idea
del comercio así que hay justamente
alguna vez vino aquí a montreal a la
radio un profesor de magill que
planteaba justamente el crecimiento cero
o el decrecimiento que iría que sería
digamos el otro lado la medalla de esta
de esta fiebre de libre comercio
entonces trump tendría razón rufo en qué
sentido américa primero es decir
proteger cada país su mercado sus
mercados y terminar un poco con estas
importaciones exportaciones como lo que
estás mencionando
no es tanto el cerrar uno abre fronteras
es el ritmo de producción constante en
que hay otros surtidos que indican que
el planeta no da más a partir de un
cierto mes del año ya no entonces no es
tanto el comercio en sí sino la
producción el exceso de bienes de la
mano con el otro
el exceso tanto en la producción como de
los consumidores por parte de los
consumidores porque si es cierto de que
en algunas tiendas y ya eso se ha
modulado un poco sobre todo en francia
donde se ha prohibido a los super a los
supermercados botar alimentos tienen que
distribuirlos en los centros de la
ciudad donde eso ya se hizo en francia
aquí todavía no hay algunas iniciativas
de grupos pero no está
institucionalizado por decirlo así bueno
está ese desperdicio de parte de los
supermercados pero está también nuestro
propio desperdicio o sea a veces
compramos demasiadas
demasiados alimentos y que no logramos
todo entonces hay un exceso tanto de un
lado como del otro y yo creo que si no
nos pusiéramos todos de acuerdo en que
lo que no creemos que vamos a consumir
lo regalará no sólo hubiéramos alguna
organización pues de algo ayudaría es
decir el problema central acá de lo que
se está planteando es el consumo
excesivo de la manos o eso es el
problema central aquí en todo el mundo
en realidad los desperdicios de esa idea
de consumo excesivo
excesivo estas estás utilizando las
materias naturales y primas de una
manera descontrolada pero si uno por
ejemplo compra compra la comida y la
come porque aparte ya sabemos que
nuestro plan que está superpoblado y por
eso estamos buscando otros horizontes y
tal martes entre entre otros en la
historia es
hay que encontrar una alternativa para
la alimentación para no terminar
destruir el planeta o sea eso se viene
pensando hace rato todavía no ha salido
el tema de los transgénicos o sea
es complejo es complicado pero hay que
buscar alternativas o sea no vamos
evidentemente en un momento dado al
ritmo en que crece este mundo o por lo
menos la población este mundo no va a
haber posibilidad de alimentar a todo el
mundo entonces yo no creo que sea porque
uno consume de más sino porque somos
muchos y ese es el problema o sea el
consumo va de la mano de la del
crecimiento del mundo y nosotros tenemos
que tomar conciencia de que hay que
comprar local y eso también ayuda el
ecosistema si uno compra local está
tratando de contaminar menos el medio
ambiente y con la menor contaminación el
medio ambiente los los bosques y los los
sembrados
digamos se retroalimenta mucho mejor o
sea hay un montón de cosas que hacer
pero no creo que sea por el exceso de
consumo sino porque somos muchos y hay
que darle de comer a tantas bocas y
encima hablando de esto en áfrica sigue
habiendo gente que se muere de hambre y
eso está bien o sea es terrible la
desproporción de esta historia es
terrible que dice nuestros oyentes pablo
bueno por acá tenemos un anuncio está
javier gonzález nunca hará que nos está
escuchando leather lítico desde méjico y
hill en abril desde nuevo brand suite
que wine cap l ella dice estoy
escuchando los o escuchando les se
interroga y dice con mi madre de 82 años
desde capelli a cara
[Música]
no sé si no sé pero me imagino que
guillén le debe estar traduciendo si la
mamá no habla español entonces saludos a
la mamá de chilena pri y javier gonzález
nungaray dice escuchándolos y viéndolos
en ratitos ahora parado en mi taxi
saludos a la señora chapman pablo
leonardo y rufo y agrega gracias por el
apoyo leonardo con el cyber magazine
todo al ciento por muy bien muy bien
vayamos a una primera ronda de cartas
justamente para
saber qué es lo que nos escribe nuestros
oyentes en ahora acá hay un comentario
rufo de la nota está tras atentado en
nueva york
trump quiere un sistema de visas basado
en el mérito
escribe rodrigo vega gamarra y cuervo
soy una españoles colombiano colombiano
rodrigo de vivar y dos estos otros
soldados colombianos que sacó un libro
recientemente que dice que bolívar fue
terrible para colombia que que los reyes
eran buenos tendencia ideológica y de
estancar me senté al lado no igual es
como dice la canción si la historia la
escriben los que ganan eso quiere decir
que hay otra historia o sea
evidentemente hay historias paralelas
que nosotros reconocemos como las que
contó alguna vez pablo que leyó en un
libro que bolívar era
[Música]
y entonces el que comenta rodrigo dice
sobre esto de trump que visas basada en
el mérito dice cuando exige que el
sistema de visas esté basado en el
mérito el presidente trump tiene toda la
razón el trump es un verdadero patriota
y un auténtico defensor de la seguridad
y el orden interno en su país no cabe la
menor duda que ese sistema de lotería de
visas de inmigrantes por diversidad no
es el mejor para los eeuu es una es una
cual es un comentario bastante extenso
bueno y dice además sé
este sentido de pertenencia e identidad
nacional que posee trump lo hace en un
hombre admirable y también dice el
fenómeno sociológico creado por el
presidente desde antes de su elección
demuestra que ha estado latente en el
espíritu de los ciudadanos
estadounidenses de bien la necesidad de
coligarse en torno a un líder que
representa los verdaderos intereses de
eeuu entonces firmado rodrigo vega
gamarra y cuerpo muy bien nuestra
opinión de nuestro oyente yo tengo por
acá un comentario de luz
sedeño ella dice con respecto al
bilingüismo una ventaja para niños con
autismo indican investigadores
canadienses ella dice hola me llamo luz
cedeño vivo en los eeuu y tengo un hijo
alejandro de 9 años que tiene autismo y
sin saber de este estudio puedo decir
que es muy cierto mi hijo habla los dos
idiomas inglés y español y recibe
terapia del habla desde que tiene dos
años que viene y recuerdo que las
terapias
me decían deje que aprenda un idioma a
la vez y yo no hice caso e insistí en
que él aprendiera a hablar y leer los
dos idiomas siete años después lo hacen
muy bien y le ha ayudado en su
desarrollo muchas personas que lo
conocen desde hace mucho me preguntan
cómo hice y les digo con constancia y no
gran recompensa ha sido ver su gran
progreso una investigación hecha por la
universidad de columbia británica muy
interesante con niños autistas o que
demuestra justamente que los niños
bilingües autistas tienen una ventaja
sobre el aprendizaje sobre los niños que
son un link hueso monolingües aquí es
bueno este es un comentario de luz blues
cedeño si yo aquí tengo un comentario de
juan alberto figueroa dice bueno el tema
es el trabajo y dice comentario nunca
contestaron mi correo que escribió para
saber si de oportunidad para trabajar en
canadá y yo
hace unas tres semanas entre el correo
para empezar a contestar conteste
aproximadamente 150
y hay otros que no conteste porque
evidentemente no se puede contestar a
todos los mensajes que vienen por esto
que ya lo hemos dicho al aire también
no somos una agencia de trabajo no
podemos ser intermediarios en un proceso
de inmigración nosotros nosotros hacemos
reportajes que reflejan una realidad y a
partir de esa realidad son ustedes los
que tienen a las personas interesadas
los que tienen que hacer el trámite
nosotros no podemos intervenir entonces
si él me pregunta si de trabajo y hay
trabajo pero yo no puedo intervenir o
sea evidentemente se malinterpreta
cuando nosotros publicamos estos gestos
especiales diciendo los nuevos puestos
de trabajo que necesita canadá la
cantidad de gente que necesita canadá
para equilibrar en los puestos de
trabajo pero no implica que nosotros
podamos resolver esas situaciones
todas esas todas esas interrogantes se
pueden resolver si nuestros oyentes
acuden a los sitios en internet del
gobierno federal canadiense allí
encontrarán toda la información
necesaria bien pasamos ahora antes de
continuar con una nueva ronda de
mensajes vamos a pasar a los temas de la
semana
la migración es un tema al que se le ha
dedicado atención esta semana y de
honorato nos habla del sueño canadiense
por vía legal si justamente tuve la
oportunidad de hablar con él pablo
rodríguez que es un diputado federal en
el parlamento aquí canadiense es el
único diputado hoy de origen
latinoamericano que está en el
parlamento y hablé con él precisamente
por una razón bien concreta y es esto
tiene que ver con la esta cantidad de
este flujo de refugiados que llegaron en
el verano acá a la frontera y que
entraban ilegalmente para pedir refugio
en sobre todo en quebec en montreal
provenientes de eeuu porque el
presidente trump había decidido terminar
con el programa que le permitía a los
haitianos de vivir y trabajar en estados
unidos y era un permiso que se venía
renovando y que obama lo había renovado
dos veces y que bueno porque justamente
a causa de los desastres tanto naturales
como
en haití había pues muchisimos haitianos
que salieron de eeuu y que por esta
política de trump decidieron venir aquí
a canadá y llegaron miles el tema tiene
que ver con una información varias
informaciones erróneas que ocurrían en
eeuu en redes sociales y periódicos
locales de comunidades haitianas y
latinoamericanas donde se decía que era
muy fácil que tiene miedo de quedarse en
eeuu tiene miedo a ser expulsado canadá
les está esperando con los brazos
abiertos solo tienen que cruzar la
frontera es muy fácil decir el periodo y
los periódicos es muy fácil solicitar
refugio y pues va a tener la entrada
permitida y yo me imagino que esto todos
los países tienen algo parecido es decir
un sistema en cada país del mundo donde
la gente los canadienses verifican los
periódicos los diarios y si alguien solo
la alerta en eeuu en los ángeles en
nueva york' y dos ciudades más entonces
el primer ministro canadiense decidió a
enviar a dos personas dos diputados un
diputado de origen haitiano
creo y pablo rodríguez que habla
castellano para ir a explicar en cuatro
ciudades donde fueron la realidad
canadiense es decir que no es no es que
uno tiene aquí puede entrar pedro por su
casa exactamente un poco entonces la
conversación con pablo rodríguez giro en
este sentido y él explica entonces que
es factible es posible venir a canadá
hay que reunir ciertos requisitos ahí
pero pero hay que hacerlo por la vía
legal porque además dijo algo que yo no
sabía que él dijo que a nosotros nos
preocupa dijo el que vengan por ejemplo
con estos doscientos mil salvadoreños
que también tienen la espada de damocles
ahora sobre una orden de expulsión hasta
el 2019 principios pueden quedar si
tienen que irse después por el momento
entonces lo que decía él es que si los
salvadoreños o cualquier otro de los de
estas personas que tienen riesgo de
perder su residencia se vienen a canadá
y solicitan al refugio político al ser
expulsados que corren ese riesgo de
canadá ya no pueden ser expulsados
sonidos tienen que ser porque al hacerlo
pierden su estatura entonces canadá está
obligado a enviarlos a sus países de
origen y eso es lo que quieren evitar
eso por un lado y también dijo cosas muy
interesantes sobre todos estos
latinoamericanos miles que viven en eeuu
y que él dice que la gran mayoría de
ellos no tienen la intención de venir a
canadá que están instalados que viven en
eeuu hace 15 20 años tienen hijos nietos
en fin y que están haciendo y van a
hacer todo lo posible para quedarse en
eeuu ahora ellos también dijeron que si
eso no funciona
quedaría abierto hay una puerta que
piensan usarla entonces estoy más en la
entrevista con pablo rodríguez diputado
del parlamento canadiense y para los
relleno tema tú has abordado el precio
que pueden pagar aquellas personas que
cruzan la frontera sin documentos exacto
el sueño canadiense y visto desde el
otro lado o sea cuando ya el sueño no es
un sueño sino una pesadilla
y eso fue justamente lo que sucedió yo
estuve conversando con marta vizcarra
que es la coordinadora de programas de
ayuda en la fundación romero de canadá
una fundación que fue creada al
principio para ayudar a los salvadoreños
justamente que llegaban aquí a
instalarse pero no a refugiados sino
bueno gente que emigraban o con todas
las de la ley sus papeles etcétera pones
y esta fundación fue creada para
ayudarlos orientarse acá en esta
sociedad a ayudarlos a buscar vivienda
etcétera trabajo llenar papeles y con el
tiempo
no sólo se dirige ahora
salvadoreños sino que se dirige a la
comunidad latinoamericana en general a
ofrecerles los mismos servicios entonces
marta vizcarra me hablaba justamente de
este caso que sucedió el año pasado en
el mes de diciembre en esa época en que
habían unas temperaturas bajísimas como
ustedes recuerdan que todavía siguen muy
bajas hoy esta mañana hacia 18 ago 0
entonces esto estos dos mexicanos que
llegaron acá por el hueco si tú quieres
y que estaban solicitando el asilo aquí
en canadá
bueno pues
llegaron y uno se instaló acerca de aquí
de mostrar el long el otro se instaló
aquí en montreal y uno de ellos perdió
la vida porque un muchacho joven de 25
años y eso es lo que no se explica cómo
que se puso a palear la nieve para
ganarse algunos centavos me imagino y
una crisis cardíaca
los médicos canadienses dicen que hay
que tener muchísimo cuidado sobre todo
que lo haces en frío es decir no hay un
precalentamiento como haces para correr
o para hacer un deporte y sin tener la
vestimenta tampoco eso es otra historia
entonces el corazón pues hecho acá nos
16 y eso fue lo que le pasó a justamente
este muchacho le dio una crisis cardíaca
murió entonces esperar a la fundación
romero con otros mexicanos amigos
conocidos de este chico que murió bueno
pues se reunieron y tuvieron que hacer
una colecta porque informaron
familia la familia quería que les
enviaran el cuerpo no tenían dinero ni
la fundación ni los otros para poder
hacer eso entonces finalmente hicieron
colectas y lograron hacerlo ese pues eso
es una pesadilla no para la familia de
este muchacho que vino aquí a canadá
detrás de ese sueño canadiense como es
el caso también de dos africanos te
acuerdas también que entraban por
estados unidos a manitoba y que se
encontraron con este frío y que uno de
ellos perdió las manos porque se
congelaron las manos y eso fue
justamente el caso del segundo mexicano
que llegó también estaba aquí en
montreal y como decíamos ahorita pues no
tienen las ropas adecuadas para
temperaturas tan bajas entonces que
tenía unos zapatitos de caucho creo
entonces les facilitaron los amigos unas
botas pero unas botas que le quedaban un
poco pequeñas entonces
apretado los pies allí en su bota pero
bueno él se puso sus botas y se fue a la
calle hacer sus diligencias y todos los
demás cuando regresó en la noche llegó a
la casa y tenía decía la persona el pie
dormido no entonces se le congeló
finalmente y aquí porque como css
circulaba en la sangre no circulaba se
le congeló el pie entonces él pensaba
que era que tenía el pie dormido y tenía
un dedo morado entonces pues empezó a
sonar el pie y todo lo demás para qué
que no pero pensando de que al día
siguiente
se va a solucionar el problema al día
siguiente el pie seguía dormido él ya
tenía dedo todavía más moral y
finalmente fue una gangrena que él
estaba dando y tuvieron que amputarle la
pierna debajo de ahora eso no se hace en
un día es ese color moral en una semana
o sea porque el tipo no se cree en dos o
tres días pero como no tienen no tienen
acceso a los servicios médicos no pudo y
no podía seguir saliendo para la
ambulancia fue cuando le empezó a dar
unas fiebres terribles que sus amigos
con lo que estaba viviendo lo pusieron
una ambulancia y lo llevaron al hospital
bueno en el hospital le primero
comenzaron por amputarle el dedo del pie
y después se dieron cuenta de que se
había progresado y que tuvieron que
amputarle finalmente debajo de la
rodilla la pierna entonces pues esas son
las historias tristes
de la inmigración de ese de esa
persecución del sueño norteamericano o
del sueño canadiense que finalmente
terminan pues en historias en dramas
bueno entonces pues la fundación romero
se encargó de eso y de eso estuvieron
justamente hablando con marta vizcarra
bien vamos a dejar el tema de migración
ruffo
el tema el tema que había escogido es
justamente que tiene que ver con la
inmigración y es justamente que en
canadá los mensajes de odio en la red
esos exprés pueden llevar a la cárcel y
esto después justamente estamos a pocos
días del aniversario de la masacre de la
mezquita en quebec donde un canadiense
ha dictan bissonette entró con un fusil
a una mezquita en quebec mató a nueve
para nueve nuevos personas seis
musulmanes e hirió a 19 otras personas
entonces a partir de ese momento bueno
eso es que la policía
tanto federal como provincial pongan más
énfasis en la vigilancia de mensajes de
odio en las redes sociales pero lo que
pasa es que hay como 18 millones de
facebook en canadá que no hay no tienen
que solamente es posible vigilar eso ese
tipo de mensajes con la ayuda de las
propias compañías de internet con
facebook etcétera entonces ellos
explican que operan sobre todo a partir
de la base de quejas y denuncias de la
población y que luego ellos ven o no si
amerita una investigación entonces hay
un profesor hay un ex policía que está
ha diseñado un programa informático para
detectar los rasgos de ese tipo de
discursos entonces hay a personas que
han sido detenidas por justamente
publicar contenidos de odio en las redes
sociales es decir que lo interesante de
esta nota es que uno podría creer que
uno puede escribir lo que a uno limpio
no se le ocurre en internet pero
que no es así y hay pues inclusive
posibles acciones de cárcel claro y no y
no sólo por eso por ese tema del acoso
de lo que uno puede escribir sino
también lo que cosa no olvidó no
olvidemos que decía por ejemplo desde
que asumió el trump en eeuu que ahora la
gente que pide visa para estados unidos
de los aduaneros la gente le exigen su
código para entrar en su facebook por
ejemplo quieren ver lo que ha escrito
entonces claro
hermano y hablando de hermanos mayores
hay un hermanito antes de ir al fin
hitos musicales vamos a y si acá tenemos
algunos mensajes de los escucha veedores
del captor cibernético guild en abril
dice tiene razón pablo intentó traducir
el contenido para mi madre ella está
feliz de sus saludos en vivo gracias
nelson contreras rincón dice buenas
tardes saludo desde barranquilla
colombia feliz año para todos al pie del
cañón como siempre y bueno y me imagino
que él también está al pie del cañón
esperándolos
de barranquilla porque ya le he hecho
los carnavales de quebec de invierno a
quien quiere comenzar hoy pero ahora más
digo aquí durante el del 26 al 11 de
febrero
te imaginas nelson si los carnavales
comenzarán hoy hasta el 11 de febrero
serían dos semanas de rumba en
barranquilla
arturo bazán dice saludos a canadá en
las américas café desde oaxaca méxico
agua la tierra del buen mezcal y de los
chapulines es me gustan sus comentarios
y nada mejor que los chapulines en el
soccer el mercado vaya allá y un mercado
una cerveza fría una tv por ti no un
acicate y un mezcal con los chapulines
lotes
bueno vamos a finalmente a escuchar qué
es lo que has preparado leonardo porque
tú haces tú estás siguiendo la
tecnología y ahora a paul tiene un nuevo
producto si es un nuevo producto que en
realidad vienen retrasados porque el
nuevo producto ya salió las otras
empresas como hace aproximadamente seis
siete meses atrás ya no tiene nada pasar
lo tiene google y ahora apple con un
poquito de retraso pero finalmente lo
lanzó su home pod y esto es una
tendencia que se vienen haciendo ahora y
que la gente lo compra yo en realidad
mucho la utilidad lo hice por eso
justamente porque muchos utilizan un
encuentro sin embargo la parte no no no
no ha quedado no me fijé me llamó la
atención el artículo porque ya hay 80
millones de este tipo de accesorios
vendidos en el mundo y yo en realidad
como digo no le encuentro mucho la
utilidad pero parece que es bastante
interesante en el caso de
a poco que lo presenta con un poco de
retardo si quiere meter en la pelea por
los más vendidos y lo interesante del
tema es que está planteando y eso es lo
que dicen algunos analistas un cambio de
paradigma porque hasta ahora uno tenía
que aprender a utilizar la computadora
el teléfono el reloj inteligente y todos
estos stores o devices ok en el caso del
home pod es
el que tiene que aprender a
interpretarlos a nosotros o sea la
interfaz es nada no hay nada que tocar
uno lo instala y eso funciona uno le
hace preguntas y él contesta que está
bien justamente ese es el objetivo poder
lograr una interacción con la tecnología
mucho más fácil que teniendo que
aprender porque qué aplicación abrir
cómo funciona cómo nos funciona esto es
un accesorio que uno pone encima de la
mesa y dice hola mi nombre es no en un
nombre sino en realidad me demoré por
uno me pareció lo pueda utilizar
bueno uno le pone el nombre que quiera y
le hace preguntas a este a este buen
arte exacto y este buen ante facto
responde y responde con
bueno con las cosas que uno le pregunta
entre comidas pero tienes que ir
aprendiendo entonces la tecnología de
inteligencia artificial con el algoritmo
que está detrás de este aparato es
sensacional y uno puede preguntar bueno
poner música quedan en la televisión
alguna receta y el monstruito contesta
si puede ver y fue una casa hace poco de
visita y encontré a una persona que
había instalado eso y dije bueno mejor
de los casos fantásticos le pides que
dice que con la temperatura para ver
cómo te abrigas o no o qué receta vas a
hacer pero lo que vi era que le decía al
aparato pues apagados del salón y se
apagaron del salón
la alarma entonces es el interés de las
cosas no piensa que es el nexo con el
internet de las cosas dice que en el
artículo de donde sea que toda la
información decía que todavía no hemos
llegado ahí pero podría uno pedirle
prepararme un café y que la cafetera se
prenda sola y eso va a ser cuando todos
los electrónicos
y eso es para es interesante digamos
para toda un sector de la población que
sufre de discapacidad por ejemplo o sea
que ese es el lado digamos uno de los
lados positivos que se le ve a esta
tecnología ya la inteligencia artificial
y es que las personas con discapacidades
pueden por la voz simplemente ordenar
pues algunas operaciones que la
inteligencia artificial puede ejecutar
como se sabe el músico este
estadounidense que ciego
stevie wonder es uno de los regalos no
no pero steve wonder es uno de los de
los que está propulsando el tema de los
de voz de los teléfonos él tiene un
staff y firmó con un contrato boca con
apple y él dice que su can su vida
cambió totalmente después de haber
comenzado a interactuar con siri el
asistente de voz de la voz lo que sí
creo que se puede decir con cierta
certeza es que ninguna de estas
compañías va a llamar a su artefacto
por dave es en obligado
en la película que es una clásica la
esta odisea 2000-2001
donde el malvado la película es
justamente un sistema informático que va
eliminando uno por uno a todos los hace
una habitación y le ha dado la máquina
te responde la máquina y la marca yamaha
1970 si es de 50 años casi 40 watts y
aquí tenemos un mensaje de nelson
contreras rico en barranquilla dice
barranquilla está en modo carnaval es
una fiesta hermosa desde hace 15 días
estamos en carnaval
me había olvidado los precarnavales pues
la diversión no informa
desde hace 15 días estamos en pre
carnavales danza del garabato lectura
del bando hoy asistir al concierto de
juglares como pedro ramayá beltrán entre
ahora entiendo porque colombia no está
mirando el mundial en carnaval
porque cuando están los carnavales uno
no tiene ordenarles en la pantalla que
ahora si en realidad no la primera
página tenemos un pequeño problema
técnico pero en las páginas cuando
ustedes visitan algún particular se
puede ver aquí arriba a la derecha es el
vídeo en vivo que bueno estamos saliendo
sale con un delay de un minuto y algo
pero es justo en frente es un retraso
estoy mezclando las palabras con el
inglés el francés lass cualquier cosa lo
mío igual y creo que sí que ahí está
para mostrarles que funciona ustedes
pueden abrir y ver nuestra misión de
esta manera en realidad es como
redundante los mismos y con esa buena
noticia aquí concluimos nos fue un
placer de estar con ustedes y estaremos
de regreso de aquí a una semana estoy
ahora con ustedes sean ahora chapman
pablo gómez leona
y menos en valencia va un fuerte abrazo
saludos a los espías y también pues les
dejamos con música como siempre para
cerrar este programa cuídense hasta la
próxima
adiós adiós
qué rápido qué pasó